the cops on
on the show on your show it's they
arrest a lot of hookers that's part of
the program and that's actually
something that
was part of your dad's job too and it
almost feels like it's kind of a
formality because the
the prostitutes know that they're going
to get picked up the cops know where
they're going to be is that right
yeah and apparently you know uh back
then in the early 70s there were so
many prostitutes on basically every
street corner in new york like my dad
had
uh his old arrest records and i would go
through them
and there wasn't a neighborhood where
there weren't dozens of arrests every
month
uh so because of that i guess the
arrangement was
all right you know they'd pull up to
this corner and there'd be 15 girls
there and they'd say all right girls we
have to take two of you
which two is it going to be and they
would figure it out right depending on
who went the night before and the night
before that and the night before that
and then depending on what time of night
it was if it was if they knew they were
going to miss
night court and the girls would have to
spend the night in jail
then sort of the arrangement was you
know we'll take you out for a sandwich
or a hot dog or a meal so you could at
least eat something before you spend the
night in jail
so that's a scene it's like a very
friendly kind of environment
well i think what did your mom think
that your dad's spending you know all of
his work day
with prostitutes um well funny story
about my yeah
the funny story is my mom um uh
my dad comes home and tells my mom this
story about this prostitute that they
arrested and there's a whole backstory
with her about whether or not maybe
uh and my dad says you know but the i
didn't think she was really a prostitute
because
she had the same coat as you
my mom of course then you know the next
day went to bloomingdale's and
burned that code thanks a lot yeah yeah
you got that nice hooker coat
you